JavaScript modules are Standalone pieces
of code that can be imported and reused
across different files allowing for
better organization and encapsulation of
functionality they're important to
understand for all JavaScript developers
in this course Tapas gives a deep dive
on modules in JavaScript hello
developers how are you doing today hope
you're doing great learning and sharing
things welcome to your channel
tapascript where you learn things
fundamentally JavaScript is a vast
language it has multiple things to learn
about and practice every framework or
library that is built on JavaScript
needs the fundamental things to be very
clear before you start attempting them
be it react Nexus angular view anything
that you pick up today we are going to
talk about one such fundamental aspects
and again it's a crash course thank you
very much for liking the JavaScript
function crash course I got a lot of
love you guys really made me feel happy
thank you thank you thank you very much
for that so in today's crash course we
are also going to do the similar thing I
am going to teach you things in and out
with multiple examples so that you will
never ever forget again the disclaimer
once you go through this course that
going through the course going through
the topic is okay but it is not enough
you have to practice so once you go
through it go through it perfectly fine
but after that make your own examples do
your own practice that's the way you
will learn better that's the way you
will learn faster otherwise no course in
the world can teach you how to do
programming you have to practice but
before that as usual on request if you
have not subscribed for this channel go
ahead and subscribe I'm sure you won't
be disappointed let's get started
[Music]
JavaScript modules what are those before
we get an answer for that let us go a
few decades back probably the time when
JavaScript was just born and people
started using JavaScript started making
their web pages Dynamic what they used
to do they used to have all their
application logic business logic into
one gigantic Javascript file then they
used to take that JavaScript into import
the JavaScript into their HTML file with
the script tag and they will be sprinkle
some amount of CSS styling on top of
that and that's how the web page will be
built okay that things used to be very
very simple because the number of use
cases people had to solve at that point
of time through web was very limited
it's not like today today we have bunch
of use cases we have a bunch of things
we have lot of libraries we have a lot
of Frameworks that are coming on top of
it bringing things on top of that we are
coding so think about it the amount of
JavaScript we are writing for one
application is also growing huge
now if we want to go in the same fashion
that we used to go a few decades back
like putting all our JavaScript into one
file and expect that to work that it may
work but it is going to create lot of
chaos what kind of cows you have written
all your functionality one to one
Javascript file that's fair enough but a
tiny part of it your friend is needed
now as an implementation into into into
the other side of the app right how are
you going to share that are they going
to copy paste the portion of the code
that they require or is there any other
way so there was definitely a need the
need of creating something which is
smaller so that it is not putting so
much load it is not so heavy on the file
size which is reusable it means that
somebody is creating it other person can
use it very easily and it is something
that is self-explanatory it means that
if it has one job to do it is very well
defined what kind of job that particular
piece is supposed to do so think about
something thing like this you have
gigantic.js file okay so sorry for this
name you know this is something that
came in my mind gigantic.js file like
imagine it's a file which is having
bunch of JavaScript code bunch of
business logic into it you will never
like you know working with a file like
this in your HTML file it's very heavy
and none of this is kind of reusable
right so it it doesn't solve anything
for you rather than that what you would
like to do you probably want to split
that gigantic Javascript file into
smaller JavaScript files which are
supposed to do something very logical
and the best part over here is that
things are usable for example module 5
needs something from module one or you
know module one it something from module
two module three needs something from
module two things like that like the key
sharing can keep happening modules were
introduced in JavaScript since es6 with
the purpose that you will keep your code
short in Javascript file and also the
reusability factor of your code goes
very high Things become more cleaner and
so that you as a developer really don't
be frustrated as and when your project
grows you have more features to add you
don't keep adding into one file rather
you keep creating module keep them
separated keep them reusable and make
your life happy so that's what is model
about next what we are going to learn we
are going to learn about something
called Import and Export whenever we
talk about JavaScript modules Import and
Export these two terms will
automatically come in because they play
a very wider role in terms of sharing
things from one module to another module
and making things working for the entire
application all right so let's get into
understanding how Import and Export
works
[Music]
let's learn about Import and Export but
before that what does Import and Export
mean I always believe that once you want
to learn something programmatically or a
programming jargon programming turn you
always need to learn that thing maybe
with real life and then it's become very
easy Once you understand the meaning of
it so let's understand what is important
export in plain English so Import and
Export when it comes it mostly comes for
different kind of services for example I
am providing a service and I want to
export that service to somebody maybe in
a foreign country and in the foreign
country there is somebody sitting who
wants to import that service in their
country and they need they use it as
simple as that so I export somebody else
input so for example we have Tina here
so Tina is a blogger and she actually
export her articles to Larry and Larry
is someone who takes basically import uh
her article and pay her some money right
so that's how the import export in
general works in the real life now when
it comes to programming the
fundamentalist kind of sim similar is
like something you have to export so
that some somebody or something else can
import and make use of it right now we
are going to get into the coding so that
we understand how the export import
Works in module what exactly the module
encoding everything will unfold then
you'll go to our next chapter right so
let's get into the query so let us
understand Import and Export with code
you know the code base looks kind of
pretty simple I have an index.html file
and then a main.js file and I have
imported the main.js file into
index.html file you can see it using the
script tag so everything seems to be
good just want to make sure that things
works so I'll just go ahead and do a
console.log and say that learning
modules right so if I do that and then
Ctrl s save it I get learning module so
everything works now the thing about
module is like we have to export
something from a module module is
nothing but a Javascript file and then
we will be able to import it to another
Javascript file so I have to first write
a code which will export something from
a Javascript file which is a module and
that's something I'll be able to import
back into another Javascript file so for
that let me create a file uh let's say
the file name is calc.js probably I'll
be doing some calculation and let me
start doing some simple calculation not
so heavy one maybe things like const sum
equals to a colon B
so it is basically doing a summation as
you would have guessed and then return a
plus b right
so a simple sum function similarly I can
have one more function maybe that is
called subtraction or sub so let's have
one more function called sub and we have
a a and b as a parameter and do a minus
B very simple now if I have to export
these two functions so that I can invoke
these two function from another
Javascript file I have to export these
functions now I am only talking about
functions does it mean that I can export
only functions no mostly actually in
your programming you will be exporting
only function but there will be time
where you will be exporting some object
where JavaScript object maybe an array
could be a class or maybe a variable if
there is a need so anything in
JavaScript like variable class function
object array you can export in our crash
course we'll be mostly taking the
example of function but you will be able
to export everything so please try
exporting a variable try exporting an
object when you press practice after
learning and going through this crash
course okay so how can we export the way
you can export is like by using this
keyword called export this is one way of
exporting so you do export and then you
do export over here and you have now
exported these two functions from
character.js file fair enough now what
we are going to do as we have exported
the next thing that we are going to do
is importing these files hey sorry
importing these functions from this file
to another JavaScript module to another
JavaScript uh file in that case and then
use it right we are not using this over
here we just defined it here so we have
another Javascript file called main.js
and this main.js what we are going to do
we are going to first import them so if
I try to import the syntax would be like
first do a import keyword and then there
is a curly braces and then you give what
you want to import from which file so
for us from of course is the dot dot
calc dot JS file so here one thing that
want to call out if you are doing a
module import or anything importing from
a module in plain JavaScript environment
you have to give this extension.js if
you don't give this extension just put
it like dot slash calc which works on
react and any other framework kind of
thing uh for but for playing JavaScript
you will get error okay so you have to
give calc.js and then over here start
typing what you want to import so we are
exporting two things from here one is
sum another is sub so we may you want to
import both of them like sum and then we
are going to import sub or if you want
to import just one thing you can import
one thing now after importing that I
just press Ctrl s and I'm getting an
error do you see that error the error
says cannot use import statement outside
of a module okay I have intentionally
created this error why why exactly
because if you are using you know
importing something from a module
wherever you are importing things you
know from a module that thing that
particular Javascript file also needs to
be a module how it can be a module so if
I am going to index.html file and I have
imported main.js over here but I am not
saying that main.js is a different than
any other you know normal Javascript
file I am not saying it's a module so
how am I going to tell it's a module
because of that it is giving this error
so I have to say type equals to module
so if I do this you see that error has
gone so it means now main.js can import
from other modules because it it itself
is a module so I'll go to main.js again
and this is done I have imported now
next thing that I can do is console Dot
log of sum sum let's put two numbers two
comma 3
so I'll get a five you get a 5 over here
right similarly if I want to test sub
over here and give some number like say
10 comma 5 of course it will return
again 5 right so I know now I have
actually defined something in a
different module a calculation module I
have exported these two things from here
I have come to another module where I
have used this right so this is one way
that you can export what is the other
way that you can export other way that
you can export is instead if you want to
export multiple things from you know one
module instead of putting the export
keyword
you know in front of everything that you
want to export you can do them together
as well so for example you can do
something like this export then you can
do some comma sub this also works you
are still getting the same five and five
output right so either you do export
keyword for with with each of the thing
that you want to export or you start
your definition finish your definition
at the end of the file at the end of the
module you export them now you might
feel like you know I have exported
multiple things from a file and I'm
importing them into another file I'm
kind of making use of them but is there
more to it yes there are more to it
there is something that you need to know
which is called as default import and
default export so I will be also getting
into that in a moment
[Music]
foreign so there is one more way that
you can export okay the one that we have
just now learned is called named export
okay named export the other way that you
can export is called default export but
before you go there let me explain why
it is called named export it is because
with the name that you are actually
exporting you have to import with the
same name for example I have exported
them with seum SUV and I am trying to
import them with Su M1 and making it
seum one and try to do this you can see
what is happening the error says that it
is not available svm1 is not available
in calc.js file basically so in the
named export and named import it is
mandatory that the name that you are
using to export your data from one
module you have to use the same name to
import it back into another module you
cannot really you know use another name
while importing there is something
called Alias by the way which I am going
to teach you in the subsequent chapter
in this course but Alias is a bit
different but you the fundamental thing
over here is like when you export and
import using the named export and import
you have to use the same name while
exporting and importing you got my point
so I'll just revert back things work
again now there is another one which is
called default export and default import
what exactly default export and import
let us see so here what I'm going to do
I'm going to create another file the
name of the file I'm going to give it
like maybe who am I dot JS okay nothing
fancy about who am I dot JS it's just
going to do like const say my name
equals to and it is going to return
say happy yeah happy all right so it is
returning a name set up a script my
channel name and what we're going to do
now we can do export but we'll be using
a keyword with this called default and
then we'll specify what you want to
export in this case this particular
function either you can do in this way
or an alternate way of doing this would
be you comment this out and just do
export default this way so either you do
it while you are defining it or you will
do it you know towards the end in
general I like you know defining things
at the top and then exporting things at
the bottom I feel that is more clear but
it is up to your personal preference how
do you want to go about it but what
about this default you know export all
about so the default export means you
when you you want to export only one
thing from a module use default export
so it means that this is your default
export default export of this module you
you understand it this way it's a
default export from this module but when
we did named export for example we
cannot say sum is a default export
because there are multiple things you
are exporting from a module so when
you're exporting multiple things from a
module you always use a named export and
with the same name you import but when
you have only one thing to export from a
file you are a module you will be using
something called a default export all
right now where default export may be
useful if you know react or you know any
component based programming library or
framework you know that the components
at the end of the day are nothing but
the plain old JavaScript functions so
you you will you usually will write one
component in a file as a module so it
means that you can actually ex export
one function from a file so in that case
you export only one component from a
file in that case it makes sense to make
it as default export because you are
exporting just one thing so that's why
it exists but if you are making
something like an utility something as a
util file something like a library where
you have multiple functionalities within
one module then you want to go for a
named export with the curly braces you
don't want to do the default textbook so
you know what is the differentiation
between a default and the named export
import right now but I need to show you
one thing I have exported the default
one but I have not imported it how do I
import it let's see that as well so
we'll go back to our index. sorry
main.js file and in the main.js file we
are going to now learn about our default
export and default import all right so
let me import so import how do you do
this there are two ways one way you can
do like import
default as now here is a catch once you
do a default export and try to import it
it is not mandatory that you use the
same name that you used while exporting
to import the same thing you don't have
to
because you are exporting just one thing
and you're importing into another module
just that one thing so it so from that
particular module it is guaranteed that
there is only one thing coming so there
is no name confusion there is nothing as
such you know possibilities there so it
means that while importing you can give
any name but in our case the function
name was say my name will go ahead with
say my name first let's go ahead say my
name and then we'll do from who am I of
course you have to do dot JS otherwise
you'll get an error so I have now
imported it so next thing what I can do
console DOT log off
say name which is supposed to return
tapascript what it does like is it on
the script so this is this is great this
works now if I do instead of say my name
I'll just give
my
channel name right
so instead of using the same name I am
using my channel name now I'll still get
the same output without an error because
it's a default import and default export
I hope it is clear to you now there is
another syntax that you can use because
this is little bit verbose like default
as you know and you're also using this
curly braces so instead of that you can
simply use something like this instead
of default as just ignore everything
ignore everything this also works so it
means that if you don't want to go with
this curly brushes you don't have to
actually use default as there are a lot
of less coding so you can directly use
the comp the function name or the
component name if it is react.js or
things like that then you can actually
use it and even in this case also you
may choose to go with the exactly same
name that you are exporting to import or
you can give your own name or other name
because it's a default Import and Export
and JavaScript knows that from this
particular file file you are or this
particular module you are just exporting
one thing so you can there is no uh
basically confusion of any kind of you
know name name problems or name
collisions or things like that so hope
the default thing is also clear default
import export is very clear to you next
we are going to learn about aliases
let's learn about aliases
[Music]
we will learn about aliases now so while
importing exporting mechanism you can
use something called an alias or the
Alias name the Alias is used while
importing a certain things that you have
exported from another modules and why we
need aliases so for example you are
exporting sum and sub from here there is
two function that we are exporting and
then when you go to main.js we are
importing those two over here right now
it might happen that in your application
use you are using another Library which
are exporting something with the same
name right there are two libraries
exporting things from the same name and
they are exporting with a named export
so it means that you have to import with
the same name you don't have a way like
a default export import where you can
actually use any name while importing so
what you do in that case you need
something to save you so for that the
Alias come into picture what is Alias
Alias is while importing something from
another module if if you want to give
another name of your choice because you
think that there could be a name
conflict you can choose to do that by
using an alias so I'm saying that the
sum as I'm going to do something like
add right I can say sum and addition is
kind of same thing so now onwards if I
am trying to do Ctrl S I will be getting
an error because you cannot use sum over
here because sum is no more known which
was coming from cap.js file it is no
more known because you have to use this
Alias name that's the way you can
resolve the conflicts that's the way you
resolve the same name conflict the same
thing that's been exported from
different uh module different libraries
now you're importing all of them into
one module into one place and you have a
name conflict that's the time you can
use aliases using the as keyword so you
can do as many Alias as possible while
importing you can even do sub as you
know minus and use the minus over here
instead of sub so I hope the area cases
were useful and you learned something
about it next we are going to talk about
namespaces there is something called
namespaces in Import and Export let's
learn about that
[Music]
at times you may need to import a large
number of functions from a module it can
happen right so in our case the calc
file is having only two functions I
think it's like sum and sub yeah but uh
in in real life programming you might
have much more uh logically related
functions you know objects things like
that into one module you may have that
right it would be tedious or too much of
code to import them as comma separated
you know as we have seen so far so what
we have seen is like when we are
importing them we are doing like comma
separated think about it like you have
seven such thing that you are exporting
from calc.js file so you have to write
them like with gamma separated one by
one one by one which is like very very
tedious right so we have a shorthand for
that and that is what is called a
namespace so now I'm going to show you
like how to use namespace and the
namespace is pretty handy uh when you
have multiple things to export and those
things you want to import into another
module all right so we have this calc
already that's fine perfectly fine now
what we're going to do we are going to
import calc in a bit little bit import
the sum and Sub in bit different way so
what we're going to do I'm just
commenting them out so that I can write
it clearly so I'll be doing like import
star star means everything right and
then give it as Alias give it as an
alias our name because star means
everything but you want to give
something as a name and this is what is
called namespace as let's give it as
something called calc right and then
we'll be doing from dot slash
calc.js fair enough so you have done it
we have imported everything give that
given that everything our namespace calc
it means that using this calc I will be
now able to access everything that I am
importing from calc so calc is having
two methods we know sum and sub so I
will be able to now access sum using
calc I will be able to access sub using
calc how will be accessing it I will be
doing calc dot sum I'll be doing calc
dot sub great so it's still giving 5 and
5 as my output 2 plus 3 5 10 minus 5 is
5. so namespace again very handy feature
when you do export and import and why
you do when you export lot of stuff from
a module and want to import them it is
very tedious for you to kind of type
things down instead of that you will be
importing Star as a namespace and using
that name space name now you will be
able to invoke everything that you are
exporting from another module great fair
enough let's move on to the next one
where we are going to see something
called combine Import and Export okay so
let's see that
[Music]
let's learn the concept of combine
export what exactly combined export as
the name suggests the combine export
means you will be combining thing and
exporting them but but what why will you
do that okay so let's take up a case for
example we have calc.js file from here
we are doing some kind of named export
so that we can actually do a named
import into another module okay fair
enough then we have who am I from where
we are doing a default export and we can
do a default import of who am I from
another modules fair enough but let's
think that we have a use case like there
is one file or one module where we need
methods from calc also it needs method
from who am I now what we have to do is
like we have to do something like what
we are doing in main.js will be fast
importing calc then we'll be importing
say for things like the name from the
who am I and then we'll be start using
them over here now there are only two
modules is is simple how about there are
like 10 modules or 15 modules so what
we'll be doing over here is like we'll
be importing 10 or 15 things on each of
the files that require methods or that
require the exports from each of this
module okay I'm repeating again so if
you need some functions or if you need
all the functions or all the things or
all the exports from each of these
modules
you need to import them over here and if
you need them into multiple such modules
you have to import the multiple such
places now here there are only two it is
fine but if the number is 10 or 15 you
have to do this 10 or 15 Imports every
time on every module wherever you want
to use the exported items instead of
that what you can do is like we can
create a module which is intermediate
which is in between it's called a
combined module and that combined module
is where we can export all of this thing
so that we can import from only one
module instead of importing from all you
know each of them okay confusing let's
see by example so what I'm going to do
now I'm going to create something called
a
combine.js makes sense so in their
combined.js what I'm going to do now I
am going to do export I'm not doing
import I'm doing export Star as calc
from dot slash calc.js do you know what
it is if you don't know I just taught
you just go back I just taught you about
namespace so what I'm doing is like I am
exporting everything from calc.js file
but in exporting as a namespace because
there are multiple things calc.js
exports I don't want to type them one by
one I know the advantage of calc as I
know the advantage of our namespace so
I'm using that and then next thing I am
going to do export default
right default as let's give a name
channel name
from
dot slash who am I
all right dot JS all right so now from
the combine.js file I have now exported
everything that I have to export so that
any module now want to import anything
from this they don't have to again
import them individually rather they
just need to import this combined.js and
from that they will be able to extract
things how let's see that so coming to
the main.js file I'm going to remove
everything I am going to remove all
these things and instead of that what
I'll be doing now I'm importing from the
combined.js file so for that again I'll
be using namespace a very powerful
feature Star as combine from
dot slash combine.js file okay so one
thing I want to highlight not many
places you will find uh you know that
that you will be you will be learning
the usage of things like this like how
to how to really do your better module
architecture so I'm teaching you out of
experience I'm teaching you like
whatever I have learned so I want you to
pay solid attention here like why we are
doing this and what is the right way of
doing things right so please spend some
time and of course do some practice okay
as and when you are learning so import
Star as combined now we have a new
namespace called combine so using this
combined namespace now I will be able to
import everything that is there in the
combine.js file right so what is that in
a combined.js file the combined.js file
is having everything from the character
JS everything from the who am I from who
am I things are straightforward just one
default export so one thing that I can
actually import but from calc.js again I
am using a namespace because I didn't
want to type all all the all the
exported item over here instead of I'm
using a namespace so to access the thing
that is there in the character JS I have
to now go through this namespace so I
have to change the name spaces so here
what I'll be doing now I'll be doing
console
DOT log so that I can print it combine
my namespace DOT I want to take from
calc so calc will be my namespace and
then I will have an access to my sum and
sub so I cannot do sum and uh you know
sub directly it is printing the result
also because now it is exposed the sum
and sub are exposed through this
particular namespace into the combine.js
file so I can only access them through
the namespace only but there is no
namespace fund over here at all right I
have just used a different name because
it's a default export import I can use
any name so this is directly accessible
from the combined.js namespace which is
combined or just name spaces combine so
I'll just copy this thing so that I
don't have to type it again and instead
of calc dot sum I can directly do
channel name see here you got the output
so this combine export is very useful
feature when you have multiple modules
which are exporting things and you have
to import them into multiple places that
time combine into one intermediate
module and from there you export it so
that in the multiple places like in the
main.js or anywhere else you just have
to import it once and you have to use it
also along with that please make use of
the namespace fundamentals that you have
learned now so that it is kind of you
very less typing you are not importing
everything think about your calculator J
is having 15 methods you are not typing
all 15 methods over here rather you have
created a dim space and when you are
importing it whatever you need you just
importing that part using the namespace
chain so hope it is clear combine export
please make use of it please practice
this again and again so that you know it
completely
[Music]
so friends are you enjoying so far are
you enjoying what I'm teaching and
whatever you're learning make sure you
practice enough make sure that you write
code of uh everything that you're
learning here so now a very interesting
uh chapter that we're going to get
started it's about Dynamic Imports
Dynamic Imports is immensely useful and
in any library or framework that you'll
be working in future maybe react view or
anywhere uh you will be using Dynamic
import a lot to take care of the
application performance loading things
at the runtime and things like that so
we'll be explaining we'll be we'll be
learning everything about Dynamic import
but before that if you are liking what I
am teaching please go ahead and
subscribe if you have not subscribed
also you can join me as a member join
tapascript as a member so that you can
get some member only Sparks so go check
out the membership as well alright so
coming back to Dynamic Imports to
explain Dynamic Imports I have created a
very simple module called gritting you
have seen it enough so far with the
previous chapters you have say hi and
you have say hola there's two greeting
message which logs just high and hola
and after that I am exporting them from
here with the name export so I can go to
main.js file and I can actually import
them say hi and say hola like this and
after that what I can do I can just use
say Hi and then I can use
say hola and I'm expecting that this
will run well and it is going to print
me hi and hola fair enough everything
works perfectly and this import and this
export that what we have done just now
is called Static Import and Export okay
static import static export no rocket
science now what we're going to talk
about Dynamic Import and Export but why
what is the reason the reason over here
that the static Import and Export cannot
be conditional so for example you cannot
dose in something like if my mood is
okay then import say hi and say hola
else don't import anything you cannot do
this with static import even if you want
to there will be a syntax error there
will be error so you cannot do like
conditional things with static Import
and Export okay other thing the other
thing that the problem is like all this
import happens at the top of the file so
whether you are using them at a later
point of time or not at the runtime
doesn't matter but the import is done
basically so if you have to take
something some decision at the runtime
that what if you want to import and what
you want to use which static import that
is not there that button is always there
in your programming you might want
something which you don't want to import
things you know in advance rather you
want to import it in the runtime only
when if it is required so on those cases
you have to make use of something called
Dynamic import and this is what I am
going to teach you now so please pay
attention of how to do Dynamic import so
first thing to do to teach you the
syntax so okay so how to do Dynamic
import Dynamic import to do that you
have to use a function like a syntax
called import and then you have to pass
what you want to import so we want to
import here greetings.js okay so this is
what the dynamic import is now once you
do this import you know passing the
module that you want to import this
import returns you a promise now if you
are new to JavaScript asynchronous
programming and Promises I have created
a extensive series on JavaScript
asynchronous programming and Promises
please go ahead and check that later
point of time but understand that it
resolves something as promises which you
can resolve it
to get the value of this what this
module is actually giving you okay now
there are multiple ways you can
I do do resolving of a promise one way
of course you can use the Handler
methods called then catch finally all
this thing or you can do like async and
await keyword okay so syntactically
asking an await may be much much
stressed forward that's why I'll be
using async and await over here but if
you want to get a deeper picture of
promises his Handler methods async and
have it again I told you I have a full
series of this one asynchronous
programming go ahead and check that okay
so now as it returns a promise I have to
resolve this I'll be using the await
keyword okay so if I use the avat
keyword so I can actually now get the
result value of what this import is
going to return to me the resolve value
that import is going to return to me is
nothing but whatever I have exported
from this module which is say hi comma
say
and then I can actually give a const in
front of it so it means
I have now dynamically imported you see
the output is also coming Dynamic
dynamically imported say hi say hola and
I'm using it now what is the advantage
of doing this the one of the advantages
you can use this this particular syntax
anywhere any place in the code not not
necessarily you have to always use at
the top level at the beginning of your
module as we have seen with the static
import you can actually write any number
of code on top of it you know sorry any
number of code on top of it like you
know uh cost ABC equals to something or
then some logic everything you get done
and after that you can do Dynamic import
this is one thing so you have a
flexibility of dynamic import of doing
it at the runtime second flexibility
that you have is like this in this
entire thing actually I can just do if
true just for example so that the you
know true false things works and I can
enter thing I can keep inside a block
okay let's try let's try if this works
this works right I have kept everything
inside a block you cannot do this with
the static import now think about it you
can write a code like if my mood is okay
my mood is okay it's a Boolean and if it
is true I am in a mood to give you
greeting say hi and say hola else I
don't want to see your face okay so
things like that right so you can do any
kind of logic and inside the logic you
can do Dynamic input which is like all
something in my opinion
okay so one more thing I want to kind of
touch base a little bit uh I would say
advanced level little bit deeper level
but doesn't matter you know you guys
know everything now so you can actually
follow it as you now know like the
import while Dynamic import import
returns a promise right that's why we
are using await over here so it means
that I can now load multiple modules
dynamically concurrently simultaneously
how using something called Promise dot
all method what does promise.all method
or the promise dot all settled method
you know methods like that do what
promise.all method do is like if I do
promise dot all this particular method
what it does basically it takes an array
of all the promises and then run them in
parallel after they resolve
it actually send all the you know
resolving resolved promises to you and
then you can actually extract the values
from them so think about a case like
where you have this particular await
like a weight uh import
greeting.js right so you have this
particular call over here
a particular module that you are
importing and in parallel you want to
import another module let's take that as
an example also I'll be doing await
let's take another module we have this
calc module right if you have not
forgotten calc so we have something
called dot slash character JS so what I
have done right now I have done
promise.all and in that what I am doing
I am having an array inside that add a
promise.all in that array I am passing
all the modules that I want to import
all at once okay you will be doing
things like this in programming when you
are doing real programming you know not
like just a side hustle or maybe even in
the side as it's not just like for fun
but if you're doing something really
solid serious stuff you will be doing
things like this you will be actually
trying to Dynamic import multiple
modules so this is one of the way now
what it returns it will return bunch of
promises okay so I'll catch them inside
Branch or promises so how I'm teaching
you just go step by step okay so that
you learn it completely what it returns
it returns promises and if I just expand
it the promise state is says fulfilled
I'll just expand it little bit it says
fulfilled means all the promises
resolved successfully the result is two
arrays why two arrays because we are now
importing two modules if we had imported
three modules we would have got three
arrays okay so in each of this array we
have the output of it this is the
Fantastic part of it so all the output
Has Come Together in this in this so
that I can now extract all the output
together all right so what will happen
now if I expand this one I see say hi
and say hola because I'm I'm importing
from greetings right I'm importing from
greetings over here now if I just expand
the second one do you see what you have
you have sum and subbed because I am
doing from calc so this is what is very
very powerful now how do you do this
this is a promise now to extract really
the value out of it what we'll be doing
we'll be doing like promise is dot if
you have to resolve it you will be doing
then
and then you get the result I'll write
an arrow function and here now let me do
console.log of result just to make you
understand like what is going on right
we'll go step by step again we don't
have any hurry I'll do um so now what we
have we have array of two modules so it
means that from the promises we got the
promise now we are resolving the promise
the result after resolving the promise
is an array which gives me all the
information from each of this module
import so the first one I got the first
module again first module if I expand I
have say hi say hola second module if I
uh do I will have sum and sub right now
how will I extract the results from this
what do you think how am I going to do
this so I can do simply
result of 0 which is the first module on
that I can do say hi
right and if I put inside the
console.log this guy DOT log say hi over
here yeah I am going to get high so
instead of that if I do hola I have it
now if I have to go you know the sum and
sub that is there in the another array
so I can go result of 1 and I can do sum
of
2 comma 3 I am going to get the 5. so
the thing that I wanted to explain over
here very very important okay it's a
quick recap when you want to do Dynamic
Imports of multiple modules you can do
Dynamic Imports of my multiple modules
using some the static methods that
promise JavaScript promise apis provides
again if you are new to it I have an
extensive video and also developed a
tool for you to learn it go ahead and
check that video where I have mentioned
the tool you can learn from the tool
like how each of this method works like
promised at all promise.res
promise that all settled all you can
learn but for now promise that all is a
method from the JavaScript promise api's
inbuilt method which can take multiple
promises together execute them and then
return the area of promises that you can
use to extract out whether there is a
success or there is a failure if there
is a success you will get a value so in
our case each of this Dynamic import
nothing but it returns a promise so we
just put them inside This Promise dot
all and after that it returns you know
all the promises then we resolve these
promises we get the result which is
nothing but again an array array of each
of this module with the resolved result
it means that whatever they are
exporting we can actually now import it
back so this is one way when things gets
complex you can actually use I thought
of just touching base because I have
used it in my programming I'm sure that
somewhere down the line you will be
using this it too I hope you use you you
like like it I hope you like Dynamic
Imports I hope you enjoyed learning
Dynamic inputs so friends we are back
again after all the chapters after all
the coding I hope you liked all the
chapters and please do practice there is
one more item that I want to mention
before I end this video there's a term
called tree shaking right so the tree
shaking is a term that is that I think
that was introduced by roll up if I'm
not wrong but it is is very widely known
term what exactly it means it means is
like now when you are exporting lot of
stuff from a module and then you are
importing all the stuff into another
module but you are importing but you may
not end up using everything right you
have done like you know Star as like we
then with an uh namespace you imported
everything but you are not using
everything right then what is happening
is like it is an unnecessary load it is
an unnecessary thing that you are
bundling when you are bundling for your
production build that is where some of
the bundler like webpack roll up and all
these things that they come up with a
feature of 3 shaking what they can do
for the developer development Bill there
is no change basically everything gets
combined but for a production build you
can enable things in such a way that
only Whatever Gets imported into your
module only that much gets burned and
bundled into the production build so you
don't unnecessarily bundle things which
you are not importing right which you
are not doing it so the thumb rule over
here be very cautious about what you are
trying to import in your module don't
import things that you won't be using it
as simple as that so that the final
production build size the bundle size
will be smaller if you try to import
everything but you don't use it this is
unnecessary lying there like a stale
code dead code so this this phenomena of
removing the stale code removing that
code that you are not going to use is
called free shaking so if you want to
learn more about reshacking please go
ahead and read and you know read from
the web there are a lot of Articles a
lot of videos out there so with that
this particular crash course come to an
end I'll just do a quick recap whatever
we have learned we have learned what
JavaScript modules are we have learned
how to do Import and Export we have
learned what is named export what is
default export then we have learned how
to combine things together we have
learned what is namespace we have
learned what is dynamic import we have
learned how to do multiple Dynamic
inputs how to handle using promises and
we finally spoke about tree shaking so
we have learned a lot now what you have
to do if you have come so far learning
everything with me
just go ahead and practice whatever
examples I have done whatever you have
learned so far just put your own
examples do practice if you have any
doubt put a comment into the comment
section I'll respond back to you and if
you like this video my request will be
you press the like button and then you
share this video among your circle so
that others also get benefit out of it
and if you have not subscribed to this
channel go ahead and subscribe because
much more interesting things are about
to come alright take a great care of
yourself I'll be back very soon with
another video thank you very much